ce qui limite l'apprentissage c'est ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de la tête de
l'étudiant cette citation et de derek
miller dans une annexe en deux vidéos
sur dix chez naïve éducation où il
explique que peu importe ce qu'on essaie
de faire à l'extérieur ce qui importe au
final c'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du cerveau de l'étudiant qui
fument et derek miller est pas le seul à
avoir cet avis si vous écoutez un petit
peu les boss de la vulgarisation du
youtube francophones en tout cas on
entend souvent ce genre de discours
le jugement majoritaire donc ça a été
proposée par deux chercheurs français et
la première fois j'en ai entendu parler
donc là c'était l'élection de 2017 après
enfin j'en ai entendu parler c'était
l'élection de 2007
et là je crois que j'ai détruit et puis
là je dis bon mais un péché et du coup
je me creuse
ah ouais ok bon j'ai compris j'ai fait
un effort intellectuel que l'électeur de
base auront pas forcément fait et
pourtant tu vois je dire je suis un
maître
j'ai fait des habitués de compliquer
machin eux et est en fête pour en avoir
discuté avec eux il comprenait pas
pourquoi des gens comprenaient pas ouais
ça peut paraître évident est en fait
cette capacité de se mettre à la place
de son public qui est un truc qui prime
et chez tout le monde voilà qui je pense
voilà fait fait à mon avis les les bons
vulgarisateur sont les gens qui arrivent
vraiment bien faire ça et
malheureusement il me semble que
lorsqu'on des bornes attendant c'est un
petit peu négligé cela on a tendance à
se donner beaucoup d'importance à ce que
l'on dit ou à ce que chacun dit et pas
forcément à penser à ce que l'on est en
train de penser et ce à quoi les autres
centres de penser et il semble que pour
bien débattre en fait il faut
constamment se demander ce qui se passe
dans la tête de l'autre et de chercher à
faire en sorte que ce qui se passe dans
la tête de l'autre aille dans le bon
sens donc c'est vrai en forme de débat
ou en forme d'enseignement justement ça
pas forcément faire neuf ans de
différence entre les deux en tout cas si
l'objectif est de faire réfléchir
l'autre dans les deux cas il s'agit de
l'amener à voir dans sa dans son cerveau
certains raisonnements
certaines réflexions peut-être justement
une suggestion du doute une certaine
remise en question des fondements du
savoir et c'est ça que l'on cherche à
faire et si c'est vraiment ça comme ça
que l'on cherche à faire finalement ce
que l'on dit importe finalement très peu
voir la communication comme un moyen
d'arriver à nos fins point en
particulier quand on fait une vidéo
quand on s'exprime sur youtube quand on
dit quelque chose
en fait faut toujours davantage se
demander ce qui va se passer dans la
tête des gens qui vont être exposés à ce
genre d'informations c'est à dire que
comme ça qu'il semble préférable de
raisonner notamment si on veut les
amener à douter à faire réfléchir à
penser les prenne différemment
il faut pas se dire qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait dire de vraies mais plutôt
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'ils
fassent en sorte que l'autre se met à
penser de telle ou telle manière et pour
cela un truc sans doute les plus
important c'est de ne pas dire ce que
l'on pense parce que bien souvent ce que
l'on pense ne va pas avoir un effet
bénéfique sur ce qu'il va se passer dans
la tête de l'autre est typiquement d'un
point de vue pédagogique on sait très
bien que balancer tout un tas de réponse
ou tout un tas de d'arguments juste
comme ça n'est pas la meilleure façon
d'enseigner et de faire en sorte que
dans la tête de l'étudiant il se passe
quelque chose qui lui permettra de
progresser
un très bel exemple de personnes qui
fait ça très bien bas c'est michael qui
est entendue pédagogique boss de la
vulgarisation en mathématiques en tout
cas puis david aussi le fait très bien
et ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant dans cette vidéo de michael
où il parle des angles c'est que dans
cette vidéo on comprend très bien que
michael je prête beaucoup d'attention à
ce qui se passe dans la tête des enfants
lorsqu'il aura explique par exemple la
notion d' angles en particulier s'est
demandé mais comment ça se fait que les
enfants classes les angles dont l ordre
plutôt que dans l'ordre conventionnelle
et ça c'est l'âme n'est d'ailleurs à
réfléchir davantage à ce que sont les
angles en mathématiques et comment il
faudrait les pensées et comment aussi
améliorer l'enseignement des angles bon
alors il ya quelque chose qui cloche
avec les angles bonjour c'est quelque
chose dont je me suis rendu compte en
discutant avec des enfants de 6 7 ans
parce que probablement moi même j'étais
trop conditionné par mon propre
apprentissage des mathématiques pour
pouvoir m'en rendre compte
mais quand on discute avec des enfants
qu'on leur montre un certain
nombre d'ong le très souvent ils les
arrange comme ceci je sais pas si vous
voyez ce qui cloche ici mais en fait
c'est l'ordre inverse par rapport à
celui qu'on utilise habituellement
traditionnellement c'est à dire que les
angles que nous on considère comme des
grands angles ils ont tendance à dire
que c'est des petits angles et vice
versa alors au début ça peut paraître un
peu troublant mais quand on discute un
peu avec eux est bien on se rend compte
que finalement c'est assez pertinent en
particulier avec ce que je vois souvent
dans les débats
c'est une frustration liée au fait que
l'autre ne réfléchit pas de la manière
d'un bonne manière il n'est pas
bayésiens typiquement et qui subit des
effets biais cognitif et ça
malheureusement il faut le prendre en
compte si on veut faire amener les gens
à réfléchir mieux ou à penser des telle
ou telle manière
il faut prendre en compte le fait qu'ils
ont des biais cognitifs pour mieux
adresser la manière de les amener à
mieux réfléchir en tout cas si c'est ça
notre but en particulier des phrases
d'indignation du genre je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut croire que
sont en fait des phrases qui tout
simplement révèle le fait que la
personne qui a exprimé cette phrase n'a
pas fait preuve de suffisamment
d'empathie cognitif c'est à dire elle ne
s'est pas suffisement poser la question
de ce qui se passe dans la tête de
l'autre j'aurais tendance à vous
encourager comme julia et ghallef le
fait très bien à éviter ce genre de
tournures de phrases si vous ne
comprenez pas pourquoi l'autre en est
venu à croire ce qu'il croit c'est que
vous n'avez pas fait preuve de
suffisamment d'empathie cognitif c'est à
dire que vous n'êtes pas suffisamment
poser la question de comment l'autre
réfléchi ce qui se passe pour la tête de
l'autre et malheureusement faute d'
empathie cognitive
il me semble très difficile de
développer la bonne stratégie
argumentative pour la mener pour amener
l'autre à mieux réfléchir à telle ou
telle question
alors je parle dans l'empathie cognitive
et c'est important de faire la
distinction entre l'empathie cognitive
et l'empathie émotionnel en tati
émotionnelle qui correspondra
typiquement avoir la même émotion que
l'autre à ressentir ce que l'autre
ressent qui dans un contexte de débat
est en fait souvent un réflexe assez
atroce notamment dès que l'autre
s'énerve on va avoir tendance à vouloir
s'énerver si on est empathique et c'est
pas forcément les bons réflexes des
débats donc je vais attendre ça veut
dire attention attention à l'empathie
émotionnelle par contre fait
prenez soin et réfléchissez un petit peu
à l'empathie cognitive à comment l'autre
réfléchi et d'ailleurs on en a pas mal
parlé dans le podcast avec juliette
ferry dany me qui sortira dimanche
prochain
quelque chose que j'aimerais rajouter
que j'ai oublié de filmer c'est le fait
que c'est un effort extrêmement
difficile que de comprendre comment
l'autre réfléchi mais c'est également un
effort absolument génial absolument
fascinant plus de réussir à comprendre
la manière dont les différentes
personnes réfléchissent et bien souvent
non seulement on apprend énormément ce
faisant et en plus on est capable de
bien mieux expliquer tel ou tel site est
à telle ou telle personne
comme l'expliquent si bien le boss d'ea
vulgarisation la malédiction du savoir
c'est l'idée qu'une fois que vous savez
quelque chose que vous avez compris
quelque chose ça devient super difficile
de se mettre à la place de ceux qui ne
savent pas ou qui n'ont pas encore
compris c'est pour ça que c'est si dur
des fois de faire de la vulgarisation ou
même faire de l'enseignement c'est que
on oublie à quel point c'était dur de
piger à l'époque on n'avait pas pigé
c'est pour ça qu'il ya plein de gens qui
font la vulgarisation parfois
incompréhensibles ou key qui sautent des
étapes et on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'il
veut raconter la baisse parce que on
tombe dans cette malédiction du savoir
on n'arrive plus à se projeter à la
place du public et sauf que moi j'ai eu
la chance d'être exposé assez tôt à
cette idée et donc depuis très longtemps
quand j'écris sur le blog je fait
extrêmement attention à ne pas tomber
dans le piège c'est à dire que chaque
fois que j'écris une phrase je me pose
des tas de questions pour me dire au
moment où mon lecteur va lire cette
phrase qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
sa tête et donc je construis mes textes
comme ça en essayant de vraiment me
représenter de manière très fidèles ce
qui peut se passer dans la tête du
lecteur en me disant voilà j'écris telle
phrase il va penser ça ensuite j'ai
introduit tel concept
il va penser ça et ensuite bull je le
dirige sur le schéma et hop il va faire
le lien et donc voilà je j'imagine une
mécanique bien huilée de ce qui se passe
dans la tête de long de mon lecteur et
j'essaye voilà de dérouler un truc très
très pédagogique comme ça une dernière
remarque c'est qu'il me semble que ce
qui manque le plus dans la tête des
autres c'est de la motivation pour mieux
réfléchir et du coup si on fait preuve
d'empathie cultive
il me semble que très naturellement on
en vient à la nécessité de motiver
l'autre à mieux réfléchir à vouloir
mieux réfléchir à donner de l'importance
à bien réfléchir et a finalement donné
une bonne connotation vous faites de
réfléchir correctement ce qui en tout
cas la conclusion à laquelle on en est
venu à
et que christophe michel dans ce podcast
probablement voilà donc j'espère que
vous allez maintenant prendre soin de
cette empathie cognitive